for today's classic interview this is
sort of a word of warning this is a UH
putting people on notice about what
we're going to be dealing with under a
trump presidency with regard to climate
change we're going to play my interview
from may of 2014 with climate change
denier Rupert dar wall why is this
relevant to the trump administration
well two reasons number one as Pat just
reminded me we don't really know what
Donald Trump actually thinks about many
issues because he had his entire life
with sort of one opinion and then he had
his campaign life with another opinion
but then he walked back parts of the
things he said while he was campaigning
etcetera etcetera we don't know for sure
what Donald Trump is going to do on
climate change during the next four
years what we do know is that the
selection of Myra nebel a total climate
change denier to transition the EPA is a
disaster and the types of climate change
deniers that are going to be involved in
making policy for this federal
government under Donald Trump share many
of the views of people like Rupert dar
wall who I interviewed in May of 2014
let's go to the interview this is this
should really serve as a reminder as a
call to action to progress is that we
can't allow people like Rupert dar wall
who you will see here and Myron able to
be in charge of climate policy and it's
really not looking good let's go to the
interview with Rupert dar wall from 2014
I'm joined today by Rupert dar wall he
is author of the age of global warming a
history which is the first book to chart
the history of climate change in terms
of the ideas politics and diplomacy
which went to form it and explain how it
has panned out Rupert it's a pleasure to
speak with you you have an article in
National Review which says that there is
a sort of McCarthyism that has developed
around climate change and climate change
science let's start there what do you
mean by that yeah what I meant was
actually I quoted from a letter by an
eminent meteorologist and AB exton knew
about a month ago joined a an avowedly
sketch
cool London based think tank with global
warming policy foundation and three
weeks later he resigned because of
pressure from colleagues who said they
wouldn't cooperate with him and were
evidently quite upset about this and he
described the reaction their reaction to
him as McCarthyite and and what did you
mean by that in other words by being uh
by be what are we saying broadly I guess
about climate science right by being
skeptical that there is climate change
happening or that humans have a role
that is that is a factor in climate
change there is a sort of very kind of
like a litmus test from so-called
establishment scientists or what really
early saying David I think litmus test
puts it very well and the problem with
climate science if it or the phenomenon
of climate science is that it's not just
a body of knowledge for its own sake for
example we take evolution evolution has
very little impact on public policy
however climate science is if you like
the feedstock for a political program
which involves radical decarbonisation
of emission cuts and so forth and a lot
of people believe that this isn't just
about seeking the truth of what is
happening to global temperatures this is
about this is a mission to save the
planet and when you have a mission bound
up with knowledge inevitably there is a
compromise if you like and some would
say corruption of the pure pursuit of
knowledge which might in some ways
jeopardize or undermine the advocacy a
function of science in terms of the
political program certainly and you know
speaking conceptually I couldn't
disagree with anything you've said that
there are mechanisms by which the
pursuit of what is ultimately the the
Act accurate knowledge or true facts can
be corrupted by various influences the
problem I have is when I dug into the
specifics
your article which will post a link to
on our youtube channel for everybody to
see is that for example you write about
the pause in global temperature increase
in the last 15 years that it's been
unexpected and that this has been
something that so-called establishment
science is not really willing to accept
I research this specifically because I
thought what better than to look at some
of the specific arguments being made by
climate change skeptics as it turns out
that assertion that climate that
temperature has stopped increasing over
the last 15 or so years is based
specifically on cherry-picking 1998
which happened to be the warmest year in
the last century and then simply saying
that subsequent years have not been as
warm it is completely not based in the
scientific process to say let's pick an
outlier in this particular case 1998 and
say since subsequent years hasn't
haven't been as warm clearly
establishment climate scientists are
ignoring the reality that temperature is
no longer increasing I feel that it is a
distortion to make that claim uh David
first of all the most recent IPCC
statements have acknowledged a hot what
they call a hiatus and they call it to
15 years long the second point which i
think is more important in many ways is
not whether there has been a pause for
15 to 17 years and we and there can be
debates about that although the IPCC
itself is pretty clear on that the far
more important point is that computer
model projections run hotter than the
observations and there is a growing
divergence between what was expected
from the climate models from the outputs
of the climate models and the of what
actually happened and that was the baked
that's what Bengston wrote this
submitted a paper that's true but what
but again what you're ignoring their
Rupert and I don't know I don't want I
don't know what's in your mind right
I don't want to accuse you of ignoring
this deliberately or simply ignoring it
because you aren't aware of it the IPCC
has already addressed this and they've
said that yes it's true the outlier of
1998 and some hot years during the 90s
did create a slightly higher projection
of temperature increase than what we
have seen and it is merely the result of
choosing some particularly hot years in
the 90s but it does not actually alter
the overall projections that they make
and remember that's what the IPCC does
projections not predictions yeah I have
to say when you get into the theology of
the difference between a projection and
prediction I kind of slightly get lost
and I can understand that it's partly to
do that they don't know how much forcing
their will that the quantum of
greenhouse gases there might be in the
atmosphere big secret and the economy
and so forth certainly but without
getting into that I guess my point is
which would be the best for you to
respond to is that the the claim you're
making about the in accuracy of the IPCC
has already been very specifically
addressed by scientists no I don't think
that is the kit when he may have been
addressed by scientists but coming back
to bake some point yeah that he was
alert he raised the issue that there is
a gap between the model outputs and
observations now you we too can have an
argument about that sure that's you know
this is a very eminent meteorologist and
he is making a point not neither of us
to and what's interesting is the
reaction to him making that point which
was extremely hostile well I I think
maybe this is a good point to segue into
the broader question right which is this
question of broader consensus on this
issue compared to so-called reputable
climate scientists who are admittedly
outliers being subjected to a so-called
litmus test or sort of McCarthyism I
think it's a bit of a UH misnomer to
that they're in any way kind of being
discriminated against because could it
not be and I asked this honestly not
rhetorical you're not implying anything
could it not be Rupert that because
there is this 97% to three percent
consensus on the issue of humans and
climate change that it would be simply
very difficult for scientists who were
part of that 97% to work with someone
who's in the three percent because what
they believe seems to go against the
overwhelming majority of scientific
evidence could it be that and not any
McCarthy istic litmus test well I have
to say in a way kind of what you what
you've described geeza is a litmus test
and you can delete McCarthy I well but
but but it ok but burgers in it's it's a
litmus test in the same sense that if
you're going to be an anesthesiologist
working in a surgery room if your views
on anesthesiology are that you don't
really need the equipment because God
will prevent the patient from feeling
pain yet that's a litmus test that if
that's what you believe you can't be in
the in the surgery room right i mean
just because we can call something a
little mark difference that in the case
of banks and he's a 79 year old
scientist who has been eminent in his
field and there's been no question about
his credentials or his seriousness is
asad that's our perfectly fair but what
about the countless others who are just
as eminent but you are discrediting
because they have a different view no
the issue with Benson was not that he
raised this question of the divergence
between model outputs and the and
observations what people objected that
strongly to what his conduct was him
joining an advisory board of a skeptical
think tank so this is not about whether
his credentials as a scientist his cakes
or his capabilities as a scientist this
is what this
to do with who he chose to associate
with all right we will have to leave it
there for today we've been speaking with
Rupert dar wall author of the age of
global warming a history really great to
have you on even if we don't agree on
much of this disagreement is entirely
legitimate David